hi
everybody um thanks for joining
uh over november pi data chicago event
and today we are so pleased to
invite irish and tyler to present a
topic
of the platform for simulation modeling
and a state of art
ai applications and now i'm transferring
the presentation
to irish and tyler thank you okay
thank you so much for the introduction
um as you
stated i'm arash madavi i'm the
simulation air program lead at any logic
north america
i'm going to cover the conceptual
concepts about
applied applications of ai today with a
little bit of introduction to any logic
and a logic cloud
tyler and i'm tyler wolf adam
i also work at any logic north america
and
simulation specialist and i'll be
showing some of the
uh applied portions of this presentation
okay fantastic okay um
let me start so um we are going to
briefly talk about simulation modeling
any logic software as a development
environment that lets you build
simulation models
um then i will briefly touch upon any
logic cloud
a platform that lets you to run and
deploy your simulation models
and then i kind of move to the main
topic of this talk which is simulation
and
ai and we talk about three main
applications
in in this specific space and at the end
i will share
some resources with you so you can
follow up and learn more about it so
this is going to be a very fast-paced
presentation and for each of these
topics we are going to briefly touch
upon them
each one of these topic needs a lot more
time than what i'm going to spend on
but uh it gives you an overview of what
is possible
with any logic and combination of
simulation and ai
okay let's start with simulation
modeling if you're new to this concept
the idea that i want to kind of convey
here is
the all types of models the main
thinking behind them that you're dealing
with a
system or a real scenario
that you wanted to make some changes to
improve it
um kind of uh make some changes uh to
get to a better
um state and instead of going directly
to the deployment of your kind of ideas
or
scenarios or solutions you can go to
this world of models which is this upper
part of this shape and build a model
a representation of your system do your
testing there
when you're satisfied with this with the
um kind of the outcomes that you see
in the simulated or modeled version of
your reality
you're happy with the scenarios that
you're looking at the solutions that you
deployed in the
um modeled version you deployed them in
reality and hopefully if your models are
representative enough of the reality
your solution will work the same as well
and you get a result
so you are basically with simulation we
weren't take you to this
um risk-free world and and let you to
experiment
and learn from different ideas without
risking and dealing with all the uh
problems that you will encounter if you
directly go
to deployment of a solution how
simulation works
in a nutshell is you can imagine it as
a um a tool that gives you insight into
the future
um compared to other tools simulation
models are really good
in handling time and causal dependencies
and you can definitely add uncertainty
stochasticity or randomness into your
model
which again is very unique these are all
pretty unique features
of simulation models and if they are
highly visual
it helps you both you as a modeler and
the
um people who are using your simulation
or kind of
end users of the simulation decision
makers or who are communicating
you are communicating communicating with
about
simulation models and your solutions to
kind of
better understand what's going on you
can convince
and communicate with it um as you see
here the idea that we wanted to showcase
here is real
applications of simulation usually need
to be connected to some sort of
some sort of data source let's say
relational databases
you have some rules that define how that
simulation
or that system works and you can
simulate it visualize it
and see the forecast or you see gain
some insights about
what will happen into the future okay
um let's take a look at some example
models for some of you who are
who might be new to this platform and
again i'm
going to kind of show you the tip of the
iceberg
some examples so you get to see
different applications
this is by no means comprehensive we
need more time for it but you can look
into the references
i will show you later okay um any logic
as a tool what i'm showing here is a
development environment so you
you use a visual graphical interface
to build and set or communicate the
rules of the system that you want to
build
to the simulation software and then um
you can run those simulation models so
i'm jumping into some
models to kind of show and i'm going to
run them one by one so you get to see
different examples of simulation models
that are built with
this platform so the first one is a
fulfillment center so any logic has some
like vertical libraries for specific
applications
this is an application of material
handling library
which is a specialized library for
simulating conveyor systems and
transport there's crane things that
kind of help you to move material in
in some in in some shape or form
and as you can see this tool is very
capable of simulating very complex
geometries and rules
in these warehousing distribution
centers scenarios
or it could be anything even like if you
have like a manufacturing setup that
uses conveyor systems
as a means of moving material in it
um and again in in all of these models
you can build
uh different ways of looking into what
is happening in 2d
3d way you can build custom dashboards
and so on so i'm moving to the next
model
this is a model about a autoclave
concrete factory this is an example of
manufacturing setup with lots of
you know custom and very detailed
operations
um that are happening here one other
thing that you can kind of observe as a
common theme
is you can build some form of ui
elements
that you call controls that allows you
to communicate with the simulation
during the runtime or at the
initialization
what is the scenario that you wanted to
kind of
look at at that point again you see a 2d
view of this i can go to a 3d view
i can see all um different kind of steps
of how a concrete slab goes through
from pouring a mix up to a time that it
goes through an
autoclave and then delivered to uh like
uh
it gets to a like a shipping dock to get
delivered later on and as i said you can
build all types of custom
user interfaces to see what's going on
things that show you
like time series of the outcomes
utilizations
um you know different states of each
component of the model
and um you know depending on what you're
looking for
you can kind of see everything that is
happening here for example for each of
these equipments that are here like
robots cranes things that are
helping the operation to happen we can
look into
how much time they spend in a specific
state
okay the next model that i wanted to
show you is called product delivery
this is a supply chain example and there
are many
like features of any logic that that are
here i'm not talking about methodologies
and like
how simulation models are built under
the hood but this is an example
of something called we call multi-method
model
which uses all kind of possible
simulation paradigms in one model so you
can mix them together to build complex
models but with very natural
and elegant structures and this is one
example of that it uses gis map it has
connections with databases so
the locations and attributes of these
objects are read from a database
you have multiple models that are
happening these trucks are moving
on real routes based on the gis
coordinates that we are
reading from openstreetmap in this
specific case
and inside each of these manufacturing
centers you have
other models that are happening locally
inside of them
and what you see as a supply chain is
the kind of
all of them working together and the
interconnected model that has all of
these parallel
objects or some local simulations
happening at the same time communicating
with each other
and what you get as the outcome of the
overall like operation or the supply
chain is the emerging outcome of all of
those interactions
again i'm just going through this
example super fast so you can see
some examples one other thing that i
want to show you
one of the classic example of simulation
modeling is
call centers but uh what i want to show
you here is the capability of
having um you know simulations that
are connected through networks and a
logic has that so each of these circles
is a call center
so there's not just one call center
you're looking at 16 call centers that
are connected through this network
and the kind of the overflow of calls
are
kind of sent to another call center that
is connected to that node
that also has some capacity to
um kind of handle the incoming calls
and there as i said there are tons of
levers
and kind of controls to build into these
models depending on what you want so you
can view these custom uis to communicate
with the model
so these things could be automated with
experiments so you can
look into all types of you know
experiments
to look into different combinations but
if you want things
these things to be manual and
presentable in the ui you can do that as
well
okay so a couple of other examples
before um
i kind of switched to the next uh topic
any logic as i said it has some um
kind of custom or vertical libraries for
specific applications i showed you
material handling this is a pedestrian
example
so pedestrian library again stimulus
movement of pedestrian inside the
space you can see the density map
and what is happening in this like there
are many useful applications for it for
designing of the layout
evacuations emergency cases uh social
distancing and so on and so forth so
that's another
library that you can look at we also
have
a library for traffic simulation we call
it um
road traffic library this one is also
um you know lets you to build micro
simulations
of a specific sections of a road
and it's very detailed you have all the
cars car
cars are capable of knowing uh kind of
understanding their surroundings they
know how to take over
accelerate decelerate keep the kind of
safe space between each other and so on
and similar to the other models that i
showed you can look into the density map
you can even because this is an
agent-based model approach
which each element or object in the
model is a
kind of an object that has behaviors and
attributes
so you can even look or kind of watch
the simulation
moving forward from the perspective of
one of those cars if you want to
um and as i said you always have these
custom dashboards or
kind of graphs to showcase what's going
on with the model
and this is the actual model behind this
thing
as i said i don't have enough time to go
through how we build these models but
just it's an overview of what is
possible with any logic and lastly
because it's relevant to the situation
that we are experiencing right now i
wanted to show a case uh
and a model that is kind of related to
epidemiology
um and this is an agent-based version of
it so how like some
infection is going to be this kind of
pass between people in a community
and the effect of these like individuals
and the
their need for treatment how it's going
to be kind of sent
to a specific for example like say a
treatment center
a hospital and how that demand could
affect the
the outcome for example i run it again
so i
kind of decrease the number of beds that
we have here
so this disease won't go away because we
cannot treat enough number of people to
kind of contain the
um the disease and it goes back in
kind of in like cyclic
fashion so there will still be some
people that are infected and the
infection comes back so what you hear in
the news about
um the forecast of the number of like
how many people might die because of
this how many people might get infected
in the future
majority of them are using some form of
stimulation so
that's also i wanted to show at the end
okay
now that we have a very kind of high
level understanding of what any logic
can do
i kind of wanted to move to any logic
cloud and show you one example and what
it is
so when you're building a model uh what
i showed you
you were in this development environment
and sometimes you wanted to just run the
model
share it with somebody put it into a
you know as on a server makes makes it
accessible to a
large number of people or you want to
just
use that model as a back end of let's
say another custom build website
or an app or you know
some form of data science workflow so
you don't care about
how the model works you want to use it
as a back end of something else
for all of these purposes um we have
something called any logic
cloud that lets you to upload your
models too so it's kind of
built into the software so each model
has this run configuration
setup that easily lets you to set select
the input and output of the model click
on it
and then you end up in um any logic
cloud which is this platform
and here and you see your own models
that you uploaded you can also see
like public models that our community
have
uploaded here i'm going to kind of
randomly pick
uh one of them let's see what we have
here you know so we have like um and and
some of them are are ours and some of
them
are like from the community just like
and the way they work is
you click on the model let's say the
product delivery that i just showed
and you can actually build experiments
here it gives you a dashboard to
to see the results so you can set the
inputs to the model
if you have any and then you kind of run
the model
on a server or a cloud provider and see
the results
if you wanted to see the animation
similar to what i showed in the desktop
version
you have access to it and you can see it
here as well
and it's kind of identical to what you
see in the
desktop version but everything that i'm
showing right now is not
running on my machine it's running on
aws
at the moment so this specific uh cloud
version
and uh if you're interested you can kind
of purchase this
and um kind of install it on your own on
premise servers or
on any cloud provider that you're
working with
okay so with that we kind of got to see
a variety of um the main
software that we have any logic and it's
companion any logic cloud that lets you
to run
share and kind of use your model
in the deployment phase let's kind of
move to the the main topic of this
discussion
when simulation and ai kind of come
together
to give us lots of um um application
real applications
of these two when we call it um applied
ai so let's take a look up like three
categories of use cases that we
identified
so there might be some stuff that are
some kind of
uh um it's um you know we try to
simplify the concepts right so it's not
like a
very clear cut but these three
applications
is going to give you a clear idea of
what is possible
in the intersection of these
technologies um i'm going to start
so as you see we have generated
generating synthetic data
we have learning environment for
enforcement learning and we have test
bed for
trained ai let's start by generating
synthetic data this is something that
i'm not going to go through the details
and
we are more focusing on reinforcement
learning and
testbed for trained ai but generating
synthetic data is similar to the regular
workflow of simulation but the
output of the simulation is not going to
be
analyzed directly the idea is um
that's not the end goal of the
simulation to get some
data the data that you get you may want
to mix it with real data as like a
to enhance your like a real data sets
for like ml um kind of scenarios
or you wanted to test some um
like let's say ai algorithm or deep
learning model on a
data or in a scenario that doesn't exist
so you build this
synthetic version of it and test it or
you might have a situation
that you want the simulation model to be
run
on a very local on a local basis
but the machines that you have are not
capable of running those
like kind of very demanding simulations
so you can generate the data train an ml
model based on those data
and then deploy those ml models on these
common hd devices that we have right now
that are commonly available very cheap
and are capable of running all types of
like neural networks
train neural networks um so that's the
idea here
that i showed um the next thing which
probably we spent a
good amount of time here is is
using stimulation model or any logic
as a training environment for
reinforcement learning so any logic in
this case becomes a platform that lets
you build an environment
that is similar to an environment that
you get readily available from
let's say open ai gym right so there you
get something
an atari exam like a game or
some uh physical level model card poll
or those simple like you know control
examples
but with any logic you can build that
environment from scratch based on what
is
your specific case and then use that as
a training to be controlled by the ai so
that's the idea
um if you are kind of new to this
topic if you don't kind of at high level
uh the difference between a regular
simulation and reinforcement learning is
in
regular simulation when you run the
simulation what i just showed you
you get the results you might experiment
with it run it with different
configuration and see the results and
enforcement learning
the learning process is happening with a
ai agent
or a neural network that tries to
communicate with this
training environment or the simulation
and learn from it and learn how to
optimally or near optimally control that
environment so in a conventional
simulation simulation alone
is is enough in reinforcement learning
you need both the rl
and rl agent and or ai agent and the
simulation to work together
to to kind of train that ai engine to be
useful
uh for deployment later maybe in a real
system
okay so how you can do this with any
logic there are two main
ways to do it um we partner with two
platforms
pathmind and microsoft
project bonsai um both of these
platforms let you to
import any logic models into them or
there are other ways to connect them
with each other
and use their automated rl capabilities
um to learn a policy from these two so
tyler is going to showcase
bonsai in more detail in a minute and
the second
option is um some a connector between
any logic as
i didn't mention this but any logic is
in java so if you wanted to connect it
to
majority of rl setups that almost all of
them are mostly in python
so if you wanted to do that you need a
connector to establish this connection
and tyler worked on
this connector called alpine that he's
going to talk about
and that is um kind of let you to do
that similar to a workflow that you have
in
open ai gym so with that i um
switch i asked tyler to kind of show us
these two use cases and i come back
and when we wanted to move to the the
next use case
perfect thank you rash thank you
all right so to start off i'm going to
show
the microsoft project bonsai platform
but in order to do that we need a
simulation model in order to
train so this is a model that's
available within
any logic's set of example models which
if
you don't know if you go to help and
then example models any logic has
like hundreds of various different
example models for
uh different application areas and this
is just one of them that was adapted
uh for this you know purpose
so in this model there's some products
that come in they seize some resources
they get delayed for some time and then
they uh get
conveyed out of the the process
and it's the model works
by there are costs associated with
different
parts of the system so if i go ahead and
run this original model
so there are costs for both using the
resources to have a product in the
system
in addition to being able to leave so
you can kind of see the
how the different cost is distributed
across
each of the various steps and down here
what you could do is you could change
the for example the number of resources
or
the delay time of the machine or the
speed of the conveyor
in addition to the arrival rate and all
of these things are going to
factor into
what the average cost per product is
so based on you know what the attributes
are
the goal is to to minimize the cost per
product
so in order to train this on
an ai a learning agent
you need to set up some some parameters
so any logic as of
the most recent version which was
actually released today has an rl
experiment
where you can define your observations
you could define your observations in
this case the different parts of the
system that you want the
in this case the brain to be able to
observe
you also define what you want the brain
to be able to control
in this case the number of resources the
machine delay time and also the conveyor
speed
and then also some input to the to the
model
and then once you've set all of this up
you can there's a button up here to
export
to the microsoft project banzai platform
and if i go to the website
so if you go to bonds.ai if you have an
azure
subscription you can get access to this
platform
and upload it to their model uploaded to
their platform sorry
and so here you have an option to upload
an any logic model so once you do that
your platform your any logic model is
now on their platform
and banzai has its own proprietary
code language called inkling which is
kind of a special language which allows
you to kind of
abstract away from ai you know the very
nuanced bear to the metal kind of
application and kind of abstract away
from it with these with these concepts
so
you can define all your different parts
of the system and then
train set up a curriculum where you set
up
different lessons and kind of break the
overall goal of what you're trying to do
down to simpler steps where the brain
can learn
and then once you've started that
training and it's progressed and it's
you know performs seemingly well you can
host
the brain on as an azure web app
and then at that point
it is exposed in an endpoint
that you can access and it has its own
url
if i go back to any logic there is a
bonsai connector object where you can
paste that exported brain address and
then go ahead and run the model
and then as you do that there is some
setup that's created that allows it to
call upon the exported brain so now the
the model is currently paused
and if i change the input in this case
the arrival rates
it will query the brain for what it
should do
in this case it you know chose these
four attributes
and it's did so in such a way that it
you know minimize the the cost for
products
and every time you see the model running
it's advancing six months at a time
so in this way you know no matter what
the
kind of arrival rate is set to it
chooses a configuration such
that it minimizes the arrival rate
so this is kind of an automated way
using
project banzai to train your simulation
models
and this isn't even limited to any logic
with that exported brand you can then
use it in
any other application as well
moving right along there is the alpine
library so in case you don't want to
have a either a reliance on some
external platform
or you want to get more customization
with your training
to do that you would need to be able to
kind of use your own reinforcement
learning algorithm
algorithms or use a native python
library to be able to
run an exported any logic model
so for any logic professional
you can export your model as a
standalone java application which can be
run
on any system that has java on it
so the alpine library allows you to
connect to an exported
any logic model and control it
dynamically from within
python so if i pull up
kind of the documentation for it so
how it works is that and i have a
example
of a supply chain model so let me
actually just pull
that up
so in this example it's just a simple
supply chain model where there's a
retailer
a wholesaler and a factory and you can
kind of set up the
inventory policy based on the the input
parameters and then kind of
run the model to see kind of what the
inventory levels are over time
the mean daily costs for each of the
facilities
um if i advance the model you can kind
of see the the system progressing
uh based on the customers that come into
the system and
request a product from the retailer and
kind of the whole supply chain operation
from there
so with alpine you can just
export this model as a standalone java
application
and then using this library so this is
just a
python file which
imports the the alpine library it
connects to
the exported model referencing that
the model.jar and then you could do
things like
initialize the the model with
parameters so here we have the inputs to
the model
able to be configured from python you
can then reset the model
advance it for some amount of time and
then get some data sets or other
attributes
inside of this model so if i go ahead
for example and run this
you're able to control your any logic
model
that's been exported entirely through
python so here's just a matplotlib
library where it
kind of extracted the data sets from the
any logic model and you're able to
visualize that
through here so you can run your own
experiment separate from any logic
in fact you can then distribute this
exported model to your
friends and family who you know know
python and they can also run their own
experiments and get their own
outputs from the model and so using this
library you have access to
all the different attributes that are
you know contained within this model
but why this is useful especially for rl
is that you might have
a let's say a traffic light model
so this is using our road traffic
library and this is a very simple model
where cars come into the system and then
they
kind of leave the system you know going
straight the whole way
but the the interesting component is
that when this model is
executed the kind of the
arrival rates for each of the directions
are different over time
so if i go to the statistics you can see
that this rate preview shows that
when the model starts up the cars going
north
north and south are relatively low
rates per hour and then it slowly
increases and in the afternoon it kind
of peaks and
exceeds what the east-west direction is
going
and so the overall goal is to minimize
the the mean
timing system and this is done through
the learning agent being able to control
the traffic light
so within your any logic model
specifically in the road traffic library
you could set up traffic lights and
dynamically set up
you know timings for the for the traffic
light
so what we could do is instead of you
know using microsoft project banzai
we can export this simulation model
which has
um you know some functions to be able to
take some actions getting observations
calculating calculating reward etc
and then train a ai agent on that
so here's our python script as before
importing that alpine library
and then for simplicity this is just
using the stable baseline library
and then another part of this alpine
library is that
it has a object
which you know inherits the
the gym environment and so there's kind
of a
custom gym environment set up for you as
part of this library
and so if you just pass the function
names that you want to get your
observation and your action and
other attributes you can then
have this environment is is
as if it was a native gym environment
and so you could plug it into
libraries like stable baselines and then
run your
algorithms and then export that at the
very end
so using this library you can not only
set up your own experiments but kind of
embed it into
you know other other libraries like
tensorflow or
or delay
so that is a short summary of kind of
what this
library can do in terms of the
reinforcement learning aspect of it
with that i will turn it back to rash to
continue where
uh he had left off okay thank you so
much tyler okay so let's
uh go back to
the different types of applications of
ai or intersection of ai and simulation
so we talked about
synthetic data tyler showed us different
ways of
connecting any logic with rl
um you know setups and algorithms so the
third application or
the third category of applications is
when you're using simulation as a test
bed
for trained ai um
basically at this point your ai or like
model
is already trained and you kind of
incorporate or
embed it into the simulation so why you
wanted to do that there are different
use cases for this
i i put some examples of the use cases
this this is definitely not
comprehensive but these are some
examples
uh one very common theme here would be
that for simulation in case one
in in conventional simulation there will
be some data
point or like quantities that you have
to specify for the system for example
when you're simulating a hospital
hospital you need to tell
the model how long it takes for some for
a patient to get the treatment before it
leaves so you need the length of
state so there are different ways so you
can put a deterministic value or an
expected value and say
that's the average or you can put a
distribution which is very common
so it's a random distribution and
depending on like
each each time that you need that value
draw a number from a distribution
but what you can do with ml models if
you if you have a very like a more
sophisticated trained model
that kind of is capable of forecasting
how much
time for example it takes for a specific
type of patient
to stay in a hospital you can
incorporate it into the simulation and
this kind of
incorporation of forecasting models or
kind of predictive models that are based
on
ml trained ml solutions
could be incorporated into all parts of
simulation model so that's
case one second case is um
sometimes you have a simulation model
and some part
or some component of the simulation it's
at physical
level or very detailed um things that
you don't
have access to and you don't know how
that works but you can
train an ml model that that represents
that behavior
or approximates that at some level let's
say you have some chemical reaction
inside
blocks of concrete that you're moving in
a factory and you wanted to know
um a specific kind of like a physical
attribute at any point of time
um so you can build an ml model that
that tells you for each block of
concrete where
it is in its life cycle but the overall
simulation
shows you the movement of these blocks
in the um
let's say the autoclave the factory that
i showed you at the beginning
so the third option would be um
if you have um if you have a
like a in in reality in a in a real
simulation
that you're in the real system that
you're dealing with there are some
components that are already using
deployed ai solutions
and you wanted to simulate that to build
a simulation replica of that reality
and that reality already have these
components so
for your simulation to be accurate it
should be able to
kind of borrow some of those ml
component
and embed them into the simulation as
well so that's another
reason that you want this capability to
be in the in your simulation software
the fourth example is um
it is a very common broad um kind of
uh case when you when you're focusing
and building
and and let's say the ml model or like a
deep learning model
so you're testing it based on data right
and everything about that that model is
about a specific component of a bigger
system
so let's say for example you wanted to
forecast how long it takes
uh to uh kind of on the right alone
but that that part is a it's one
part of like a longer
kind of process there are multiple steps
you have a model for one
part of it that gives you forecasting
capability if you wanted to see the
overall
picture and how that overall system will
work when you
deploy this newly learned knowledge
into the overall system and see how it's
going to affect
that um that is when you can simulate it
with this result we did this uh kind of
in this case so you you trained your
model you know it's one component so for
example it gives you a better
forecasting
of your demand in a supply chain but you
want to know okay
so with this newly gained knowledge how
is going to affect my operation if i
continue with
the um the previous for example um
you know inventory policy that i had is
it going to impact it in a positive or
negative way
now that i know more maybe i need to go
back and adaptively change my
um inventory policy as well right so
that's case four
case five is just embedding ml solutions
into simulation to visualize it
so ml models are basically math and it's
hard to
show like the effect of mathematical
models uh
just um you know it's hard to visualize
them for people to say okay how is going
to improve my operation you can embed
them into a simulation and simulate the
effect so you can visualize and
kind of get a more intimate kind of
understanding of what's going on
and case six is uh kind of fell into
what tyler just showed us
so when you are doing your rl training
at the end you get a policy which is
like a a like a trained ml model
basically like a neural network that
kind of everything is um kind of like it
works like a function
you send the observation it tells you
what to do it it gives you the optimal
actions to take
so you can bring back that trained a
model
into a simulation model and simulate it
with this optimal controller near
optimal control policy
and see how good that policy actually
behaves or what would be the effect of
that pilot so you're you can basically
test
your the results of your rl training
into this in the simulation to make sure
that it works as expected
so these are the use cases but the
implementations are
basically the same regardless of what is
the reason that you are doing this
then implementation it's just about how
you embed an ml model into a
simulation and there are many different
ways to do it
uh we pick like two cases we are
partnered with um
h2o.ai in case you are using their
driverless ai
technology you can natively incorporate
the train ml models from their
like platform into any logic that tyler
will showcase in a minute
and the second approach is through a
connector
that tyler developed called um pipeline
that lets you again
communicate with python code and in
python code and you know majority of
trained
models are going to be in python so it
gives you that capability there is a
third option
that is um in both of um reinforcement
learning
and tested for trainiai that works with
our cloud platform we didn't show it
here just for the sake of brevity
but these two cases h2o.ai
and pipeline are going to be the next
part that tyler is going to demonstrate
thank you rash right
so um for those that don't know uh h2o
has a software called driverless ai
which is
uh automatic machine learning platform
where you can
interface through it either with the
dashboard or through
kind of a python library once you're
done
kind of and you have a trained model you
can export that as a
mojo file and here we have an example of
a product delivery
model which is a supply chain model but
specifically if i go into the model
folder
you can see that there are two mojo
files which are loaded from
which are downloaded from h2o
in this case if i go ahead and run it
you can see how the model makes use of
that
it's kind of a more relevant model as it
you know it takes the product delivery
model that's part of
any logic standard example models and it
adds some
forecasts using
you know with or without kind of covit
so
with that you can run the model and then
it utilizes the
uh mojo files for both
kind of calculating different values
such as like the temperature and also
some other
attributes such as you know how long it
takes
to uh fulfill a product
and so this is kind of impacting
dynamically within the simulation model
whereas you know the original simulation
model had
you know much less fidelity to it so now
it
is able to be kind of further
made more accurate by these
implementations
so that is h2o and then the
as far as the pipeline example so
pipeline is a
custom library for any logic which is
currently on
github and is open source and is
available for anybody to download
within any logic you can add your own
custom libraries that you can add
enabling you to
kind of have your own custom objects
that you can drag into
various models in this case
this pipeline library is a provides a
communicator object which utilizes a
instance of python which is installed on
your own system
and you configure it to choose you know
which
version of python that you want based on
your system set setup
and then through that there are
functions within this object which allow
you to communicate with that
with like a live instance of python
so you could utilize any of the
libraries that you might have
installed in python or you can which
includes
you know the the test but example which
i'll show shortly
so this first example uh is a system
dynamics model so there are some
various stocks with some
flows between them which have their own
mathematical equations and then there
are some
three different 2d plots which kind of
showcase how these three stocks are
interacting with one another
so what i did is i have a
local python file which is relative to
this any logic model
which utilizes the matplot lib
library to display a live 3d plot
so there's some kind of basic setup for
the plot and then there's some
functions which are used as endpoints
so this python file will execute
and be running in the background of the
model and i'll be able to call these
functions from within my any logic model
which is in java so when the model
starts up
it will create this python instance it
will import that plotter file
and then be able to call those those
functions
so if i go ahead and run this
see that
so here on the left is my any logic
model and on the right is my
live matplotlib 3d window which i can
then
you know see it from different angles
and it's kind of
passing data from my any logic model and
updating this plot and so i can
there are some sliders here which allow
you to kind of configure
how the interaction is happening and you
can see that as i
change one it changes the other
and so the way that this this happens is
that
through this cyclical event it runs a
function
and specifically it runs the append
function passing the actual data
from my any logic model to that python
environment
the other nice thing about this library
is that it
is able to run in parallel with itself
natively without any extra java code
so if you have something like a certain
experiment
in any logic which allows you to kind of
run
parameters variation or monte carlo
these could all run in parallel without
like i already said without any extra
code
so it kind of makes things easier on in
terms of the implementation side of
things
but why this might be more practical is
in a
situation where you have um
where you have uh data sets within
python that you train
using let's say tensorflow and you've
trained it with
your test data and that's you know
seems to be accurate but you want to
kind of see how it
interacts in a kind of more dynamic
environment so in this example
it's a simple hospital and there are two
different
trained networks that we're trying to
care us one for the arrival rate of
patients and another one for the
length of stay based on certain
attributes
and the overall goal is to figure out
what an optimal capacity for this
hospital is and so there are sources to
the original data sets below
so when this starts up it imports those
h5 files which are again similar to the
other example in my model directory
and it interfaces uh with that uh python
environments through
various functions that were set up so
here you can see it's
updating the arrival rate every four
hours and there's this delay block which
is
getting the length of stay time
for any patients that are flowing
through the system
and so there are some metrics where you
could see the daily arrival rate
the another various metrics such as you
know
how many people are in the system and
how many days they
end up staying and so you can kind of
dynamically
change this and see how it impacts over
time
so you can kind of find an optimal
capacity for the hospital
and with that that is both of these
libraries so i will turn it back to
a rash to finish up
okay thank you tyler let me share my
screen
[Music]
okay um just as a summary of what they
discussed about the intersection
of simulation and and
ai we talked about three different
different categories
of uh use case generating synthetic data
using simulation as the learning
environment for reinforcement learning
and using simulation as the testbed for
trained ai
and as you probably noticed as we
discussed different technologies
we are completely aware of the fact that
people
uh have different workflows different
setups and because of that we are
providing multiple alternative for each
of these um
kind of approaches so we have things
like any logic cloud that lets you to do
things um use a model as a backend and
just
communicate with it with api and use the
computational power of
cloud or servers or you you have
connected libraries to python like
alpine and pipeline if you wanted to
use um your local machines and
or communicate with other languages like
python
um and you're also partnering with auto
ml and auto rl
platforms like h2o.ai microsoft
project bonsai and pathmind to give you
a variety of choices depending on
what your workflow is if you're a
practitioner if you're a researcher if
you are
enthusiasts that wanted to try these if
you are
like you wanted to even contribute and
open source
projects both alpine and pipeline are
open source if you want we would be very
happy to have you as as collaborators on
those two projects
and that would be great and both of them
are open source and
um you can contribute to them and see
how that works maybe you can even
utilize them for other applications as
well
um so with that said i wanted to
just to finish off i wanted to give you
an overview of
where to go in case you wanted to get
more information
so this is any logic website if you go
to features
artificial intelligence here you get
access to
like um all of these platform bonsai h2o
dot ai and pathmind there is a landing
page for each of them so you click on it
and say i wanted to
kind of see more you get to see all the
connectors everything that you need to
download to make it work
you have example models here and kind of
everything that
kind of setups your uh workflow
the next thing is the software itself if
you want you go to download
page and you can download different
versions of any logic
if you are a student or just wanted to
use it for personal
use you can use plhs it is completely
free
and now it has these rl experiments
which is
also free so you can use it with um
bonsai or pathwine if you want to
and you can export your simulation
or rl experiments to test those
platforms as well and professionals and
researchers are
like paid versions of any logic but both
of them are also available for
a month of free trial if you want please
download them
and take a look at the capabilities if
you want
more information about this tool what
has been done with it
i suggest you to go to resources look
into white papers
case studies be companies that have been
using any logic for years
books several free pdf books are here
and video tours you can look into uh
previous webinars and training material
and if you are interested to get to a
training please register
here and we will kind of help you with
learning any logic okay so i have like a
qr code for
for some of these links here um emails
uh for me uh or ash tyler and
also here specifically if you're
interested in the
the kind of the libraries and you want
to collaborate and you have questions
tyler is available for you and i i put
my colleague david kirby um who is a
sales director in logic north america
email here in case you wanted to learn
more about the pricing or
a solution that works for your company
please contact david
and if you have any other questions from
me tyler or
david please feel free to reach out we
are even interested
to get your feedback in case you have
some ideas
that based on what you saw and you think
that there is room for
collaborations or things that kind of
works uh to improve this setup
for you and we can learn from you as
well
so with that thank you so much for
attendance we are
ready for the q and a session well thank
you a russian tyler
i have a question um so for the learning
edition of
any logic does it have the uh
capacity uh for beginners and learners
to
explore what you have talked about today
like their
uh you know um reinforcement learning
applications you have shown yes
so that's a great question so uh with
the
um so the the free version has
capability for um for
it has this new experiment called rl
experiment that lets
it let you to export models for both
pathmine and bonsai in case you are
interested in
automated rl if you want to do
everything manually
both so you can use um alpine which is a
free
kind of library that you can freely
download and
kind of make the connections to your
python code
locally and the same goes for a pipeline
which is another
free open source library available for
ple users
and the software itself the ple version
is very capable it's actually the
limitations are very generous so
definitely it cannot be used for a very
like a large complex model but the
limitation is mostly on the licensing
not
on the capability so you are not allowed
to use it for
um you know professional or like
commercial use
wonderful yeah the um
environment is very beautiful with so
much
uh 2d and 3d visualizations
i'm curious that when a user configured
this kind of um
visualizations with all these animations
um so on and so forth
behind that does the software also
generated the associated
java code or correct
yes so any yes any logic itself
when you build a model you are using
this graphical interface a very
or high level ways of describing how
that model works mostly with flowcharts
you will specify for example
like let's say you are building uh that
intersection that i showed with cars
you're using a flowchart to say where
cars are coming from how many of them
are coming
per like specific uh you know
time and um and then you kind of guide
them with flowchart where they should go
through
and then they leave the model so that's
a very high level declarative flowchart
that you connect with uh like an
environment that you draw with
um elements that we call a space markup
so you draw like all the car
the road intersections let's say um
traffic lights and things like that and
then you connect that logical
flow chart with the space markup to have
the association and when you run the
model
unlike any logic definitely generates a
java code in the back end
and kind of takes care of the um
you know the complicated um
kind of management of the events that
are supposed to happen for the
simulation
so you as the user are dealing with a
very graphical
easy to use drag-and-drop platform so
that's the
objective of this offer fabulous
thank you i hope you will come back to
give another talk
in the near future and meanwhile um
have a very happy uh holiday year and
holiday season
to you and thank you for inviting us and
yeah we definitely are interested to
come back and maybe
pick a specific topic and dive deeper
into one of these
so this was an overview of everything
but there are a lot into any of these
topic and we can definitely
kind of cover them in more depth in the
future
thank you again for the invitation and
thank you for your time today
thank you have a good evening everyone
i'm going to stop the recording now